[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in peter king nbcsports.com
columnist of course the great column
that you can read
every monday morning football morning in
america pete good morning how's morale
uh morale is fine the draft is over um
the long national nightmare of hype for
two months over a
seven round event is over and so it's
always a happy day the monday after the
draft in the king house
yeah i know that you're so deeply
involved in it but you know
for the outsider looking in i mean it's
still
it gives hope to everybody and that's
that's
that's what's great what sporting event
gives hope
quite like the draft does that we're
talking about jacksonville we're talking
about the jets we're talking about the
lions
the bengals that that's all you ask for
is hope i went to jacksonville on friday
dan and i watched
trevor lawrence get limo'd into the
stadium with a
a crew of third graders there holding
signs and screaming for trevor lawrence
like it was
a crowd at laguardia airport or whatever
it was called when the beatles came in
or jfk and it was just cute and fun
and you know shad connie's worth 8
billion dollars he's 70 years old
and he was jittery and nervous he's just
like a little kid and so
that's fun i really really do enjoy that
part of it i just think it's
uh it's just unbelievable what it's
become kyle shanahan
told me over the weekend he goes he goes
it's just
it was unbelievable to sit back and
watch this honestly with everybody in
the world
screaming at us for taking mac jones
and we weren't gonna take them and
we just couldn't say anything so anyway
yeah it was a weird
a weird draft process but do you think
it started because
of the speculation of what kind of
quarterback
kyle shanahan wanted and the people who
were speculating
know the shanahan adam schefter is
friends with the shanahans
chris sims is great friends with kyle
shanahan
yeah i mean he was a college teammate of
his at the university of texas so i
think
you know it's a total absolutely
understandable storm because
understand one thing dan this is from 35
minutes on the phone with kyle shanahan
this weekend
i can tell you categorically that
they very seriously considered mac jones
and i i would not have been shocked
after listening to kyle shanahan
talk about how much he loved mac jones
if three days before the draft he said
to john lynch hey
are we sure you know we love mac jones
but
but i do think there is this element
of 2021 football and beyond
that really drew them to trae lance
and the element of making the sort of
off-schedule plays
and the simple fact dan as i as i said
my column
there's two minutes and 37 seconds in my
column today
that anybody who really likes football
and who wants to know why did the 49ers
pick
uh trey lance kyle shanahan explains it
in perfect almost detail
about the process he went through and
what he did and i just let him go
and and and i think he understood
exactly what he wanted and
he came to grips with the fact that he
loved
mac jones's accuracy loved it he's most
accurate had the most accurate season in
the history
of major college football this year but
i think at the
end of the day he was happy enough with
trey lance's accuracy
and loved all the other parts
potentially of his game
that trey lance brought he's peter king
the column is football morning in
america nbcsports.com give me the teams
that feel like they really changed this
weekend
i think the new york jets feel like they
changed they added so many good
offensive pieces
and again look they've been drafting
quarterbacks forever
uh since namuth left and and quite
honestly
no one knows if if he's going to be
broadway zach or not
but they drafted guys who they can see
tomorrow are going to give zach wilson a
real chance and i think the biggest one
they drafted
was a fourth round running back named
michael carter who
i think everybody in new york feels like
easily could be a starting player there
very soon
i think the two other teams that did
really well like in their own eyes
i think the detroit lions getting
the best tackle in this draft to do
what dan campbell wants so badly not
bite kneecaps
but to control the line of scrimmage and
to be a leader
and to like being in detroit
which not all players do
but he was just so enthusiastic about it
and i think they they had a good draft
through and through
the other team is the miami dolphins
because i think
jalen waddle first of all there's so
many good
explosive players in this draft but the
thing that jalen waddle gives you
is the ability maybe to have drafted a
very good wide receiver
plus devin hester you know he might be
this generations great returner
and and i just think those are a few of
the things when you
look at you know what teams did they
really
changed their teams give me the team
that you
don't understand their strategy well i
mean i hate to be a cliche but i just
you know the raiders picking alex
leatherwood at 17
was just a really weird pick to me um
because i think i would be surprised
surprised
if they weren't able to move down you
know with somebody
to get something because i you know look
i did a lot of pre-draft work on the
mock draft and all that and i just
i'm serious i just never heard alex
leatherwood's name
and so maybe maybe somebody would have
taken them at 20 or 21 or 22. i don't
know
but i thought that was weird and
unfortunately because i really like mike
mack and i think he's
he's very very good at his job he's had
a couple of high
picks bomb out or at least not
fulfill the promise you know cleland
furl and
and damon arnett so far and i think
there's a lot of pressure coming in that
alex leatherwood has got to pretty much
play from day one
why do you think denver shied away from
a quarterback in the first round
i just don't think there was one they
loved
as much as they thought they should
to pick one either at seven
if they thought they had to trade up a
little bit or
or to pick one that high and i think the
other thing is dan
look vic fangio and this has nothing to
do well vic fangio's a defensive coach
so of course they're going to take
patrick certain i think
they wanted to take a great player
at nine and george payton this
wasn't about he could have taken a
quarterback at night if he was in love
with justin fields or or mac jones but
clearly by what they did denver wasn't
really in love with one of these
quarterbacks and figured that
hey look drew lock teddy bridgewater
they'll get us through this year we'll
revisit it at the end of the year
what's jimmy g's status in san francisco
i honestly think he's going to start
opening day
and you know he might not but
i remember talking to john lynch when
the trade happened and one of the things
he said is that look
look at what's happened to us in the
years that we did not get a full season
with a really good quarterback you know
look everybody looks at the 49ers is a
great franchise but in
three of the four years of john john
lynch and kyle shanahan they've won
six six and four games
you know they everybody's kind of
blinded by the super bowl year
and probably well they should be
injuries really killed them last year
but the fact is
they did not want to be stuck with only
one good quarterback the only way
they were trading jimmy garoppolo is if
they got a one for him this year
and and i don't know if new england ever
offered that second round pick for him
uh but i that would not have been good
enough this year for the 49ers because
they believe
they're not going to get short uh caught
short at the quarterback position again
texans draft a quarterback davis mills
out of stanford
um is there more to this
i think i don't care what they say i
mean
you know you have you're an expansion
team the texas
the houston texans are an expansion team
you have
one pick in the top 80 of this draft one
pick
and you pick a quarterback when you have
a quarterback on your roster
who is 25 years old you've just given a
jillion dollars to
i mean look i i'm sorry you know with
nick casario saying oh no this is not
about any one person or whatever his
quote was
i mean that's silly i believe this
this was the most meaningful pick in
this draft at least as far as i'm
concerned
as to what it said about the current
roster
which now leads us to aaron rodgers
what's what what if you're summing up
what happened in the last week and where
we are today
monday morning at 9 36 eastern
how would you do that you know obviously
this has been in the works for a while
aaron rodgers has been unhappy
i think it dates to last year uh last
year's draft where they drafted his
successor
um and evidently now
evidently did not tell him that they
were drafting his successor
and so with that being the case
um the interesting part of this
dan going forward i think this all just
didn't happen in the last year
you know i think it this is me just
simply reading the tea leaves
i've not talked to aaron rodgers so i i
can't say this for sure but
in my opinion aaron rodgers has to be
feeling like
look the packers have been doing
business the same way
since ron wolf took the job 30 years ago
and that is
general manager picks players coaches
coach players
players play football and that's it okay
like you know i i don't know this but i
mean
you know would would brian go to kunster
with the coaches
ever like call them in and say hey you
know what do you
what what do you think what do you think
we should do or
what do you think of this practice squad
player or whatever
and i just don't think that happens and
i think he's got some of the same
frustration
probably as russell wilson has you know
listen to me i'm out there
i'm the guy who is sort of the titular
head of this franchise
that as i go so goes the franchise talk
to me consider me
and it's just not the way the packers do
things and
i don't know that they're gonna change
dan but
and i'm i'm just telling you this
reminds me
so much of exactly what happened 10
years ago with carson palmer
he told the bengals i'm not playing for
you he had played there seven years i'm
not playing for you anymore i'll retire
yeah sure you'll retire then he retired
and and the raiders called the bengals
that october
after jason campbell got hurt and said
we want to make a trade for carson
palmer
and they did it and so i this wouldn't
surprise me
as you know aaron rodgers is
very strong-willed and if he feels in
any way like he's been wrong
i i just think he's gonna he's he's
gonna hold his ground
and you know he when we talked to rogers
a couple of weeks ago
and and i said take me back to that
draft night and he
said look i'm watching just like you are
and i find out we're drafting a
quarterback
i think in a situation like that pete i
don't think quarterbacks should be
involved in
drafting because they don't know
anything about this but also
you know unless it's joe burrow with
jamar chase and you go okay i trust your
instincts
free agency you played with a guy you
want to bring in gronk antonio brown tom
brady all right
you know i'll give that to you but if
you're going to draft a quarterback's
replacement
then i think you at least have to say i
don't want you to be shocked
but right like that's all that's that's
a courtesy
that i think that he has earned in green
bay he doesn't have to be involved in
personnel decisions
but when you're drafting your successor
and you're sitting there having a drink
and all of a sudden the packers are on
the clock and they draft your successor
to me that's a slap in the face
i i agree with you and if that's exactly
the way it happened
i i don't agree with that you know you
shouldn't
you shouldn't handle things that way and
look
deep down maybe some in the packers
would say
good it uh it stuck a little cattle prod
up his rear end and he played he had
maybe the best year of his life
he certainly had one of them and he was
the mvp but still
i don't want to motivate people by that
that way i
i think i think you've got to be upfront
with guys
who've been so great and so valuable for
your franchise
is aaron rodgers the starting
quarterback for the packers
week one my bet would be no
i mean i jus i don't see it i just think
this is going to get particularly ugly
um there's not gonna be any media people
who are gonna have any vacation
between now and labor day weekend sorry
everybody
uh and i just think
if if at some point at some point
um i think green bays might have to come
to the realization that they're either
going to be playing jordan love
or if they think he's not ready they got
to go find somebody
you know maybe they look i mean how in
the world could this ever happen
but maybe they look uh three hours south
and
look at nick foles who seems to demand
without a country
in chicago and how crazy would it be if
nick falls
out duels andy dalton early in the
season in a bears packers match
i don't know what'll happen but but who
would be
in line for rogers like if you you know
gruden loves
any quarterback that's not his
quarterback but look i think gruden
i think i think gruden i i'm and i don't
know how they could do it
i think gruden would love to have aaron
rodgers throwing julio jones this fall
uh and and again i don't know how they
can do it or what they would do
but uh i just think i i if i'm looking
at it
i think the packers would probably
consider it an afc
team because they don't want aaron
rodgers ruining their dreams until the
super bowl
um so you know denver seems to make
sense
uh and the raiders seem to make sense
and and obviously there's a bunch of
other teams but if you're aaron rodgers
you know and if if you're the packers
you like to find a team who looks at
aaron rodgers
as the missing piece to really get us
over that hump those are two teams that
really stick out even though
you know carr is certainly not an
expendable a totally expendable guy
and the other thing you look at dan is
what could they trade
i mean i think getting derek carr back
would be pretty good
and maybe the next two ones uh for
for from vegas i i don't know how
exactly they would make a trade like
that
but they would have to give i think
derek carr and something pretty
significant
pete thanks for joining us as always
love the shirt uh manny's pale ale in uh
seattle
it's fantastic yeah it's my go-to when
i'm out there which is not nearly enough
not not nearly often enough i mean thank
you pete
okay dan take care that's peter king
football morning in america is the
column nbcsports.com